ici 32 km de documents sont conservés
dans des conditions spécifiques créés en
1794 les archives départementales sont
implantés à montigny le bretonneux un
service public méconnu ouvert à tous
objectifs de la structure collecter les
archives identifier et classer les fonds
et bien sûr les mettre à disposition la
structure conserve l'histoire du
département
au moment de la révolution française ont
été collectées et conservées rassemblé
d'anciens titres de propriété des
grandes familles qui ont composé le
territoire des grandes administrations
de l'ancien régime
les archives ont une vocation de
transparence administrative et d'accès à
des sources historiques large sont
collectés les archives ayant une valeur
importante notamment les actes produits
par les administrations
on a un temps en fait j'ai dit hier de
décantation des archives dans les
services qui correspondent à leurs
besoins administratifs et passé ce
besoin administratifs ont fait un
tricheur les archives et bien évidemment
en conserve qu'une toute petite part de
ce qui a été produit
les archives les plus demandés des
documents liés à l'histoire du
territoire aux grandes administrations à
la justice ou encore les fonds
nécessaires à la généalogie des archives
accessibles à tous sur présentation de
la carte d'identité on leur permet
d'accéder plus facilement à
l'information c'est un petit peu
complexe ans de retrouver des documents
d'archivés ça se fait pas toujours
simplement et à partir de là nous reçoit
ses boîtes en salut écrivain peut les
consulter directement sur place
les archives départementales dispose
d'une vingtaine de magasins d'archivés
spécialisés ici le climat le volume
d'humidité et la température sont
contrôlées les documents sont disposés
dans des boîtes de conservation
spécifiques et adaptées qui protège le
document de l'humidité d'une partie de
l'humidité puisque ça absorbe aussi
l'humilité du feu de l'eau s'il y avait
à
un incendie ou un désastre une
inondation la boîte en elle même mais
longtemps avant de devenir humide et
donc protège de documents maximum
document le plus ancien conservés aux
archives un diplôme de charles le chauve
datant du 9ème siècle
c'est un document de réemploi un
parchemin de par un poids qui avait été
utilisé pour refaire de couverture d'un
ouvrage relié et donc c'est au moment
d'une restauration en d'herlies l
ouvrage qu'on a retrouvé ce document
extrêmement siens une quarantaine de
personnes travaillent sur les fonds
d'archivés ici le dépôt arrive à sa
limite